and finally new rule if Republicans if
Republicans are going to keep calling
states laboratories of democracy they
have to start looking at the results
from the lab California raise taxes on
the wealthy a lot and our economy is
booming
we just passed France and India to
become all by ourselves the world's
sixth largest economy
soon-to-be fifth thanks England
whereas states like Kansas and Louisiana
that went back to the old trickle-down
theory of cut taxes on the rich and
they'll always do the right thing
our financial catastrophes the results
from the lab are in our mice are
thriving yours are dead now they say the
definition of insanity is trying the
same thing over and over and expecting
different results but I'm beginning to
think that's actually the definition of
being a conservative because because
it's not like we haven't tried trickled
down before many times it's not new
despite the fact that when he took
office kansas governor Sam Brownback
said we've got a different way and it
works and by works he meant it works the
night shift at Del Taco yes somehow for
the millionth time when rich folks got a
big tax cut they pocketed it and now
Kansas is in a recession with a huge
deficit the band Kansas has more money
down in Louisiana Bobby Jindal tried the
same stupid thing that Brownback did and
big surprise the same result a billion
dollar surplus became a two billion
dollar deficit and now everything's
getting cut because apparently when you
take in less money you have less money
to spend crazy I guess you are at richer
the less cash you have unless you're
Donald Trump okay so now let's travel
west to the laboratory called California
which not that long ago was being called
an economic basket case unmanageable
they said a failed state but this is
when we had either Republican led
legislatures or a Republican governor
who turned out to be such a disaster
even his maid said I can't believe I
[ __ ] that guy
and and here's the part where the
experiment becomes crystal clear because
after arnold left office we eliminated
what scientists would call variables in
this case the republicans democrats from
Governor on down control every office
and voting body in this state so we can
really study what happens when liberal
policies are tried unimpeded and the
only thing I have to say to Republicans
about that is scoreboard [ __ ]
Republicans claimed cap-and-trade would
drive up utility bills but our
electricity tab is now among the
cheapest in the country and I ought to
know because I use a lot of juice in my
basement to grow my orchids my orchids
working there pretty yeah
California California gave illegal
immigrants driver's licenses and college
tuition and conservative said
encouraging immigrants like that would
destroy the economy but it didn't
immigrants just take jobs Americans
don't want to do like raising their
children
so so maybe maybe we are being invaded
by Latinos and Asian's but it's not
making us weaker it's making us hotter
we did all the stuff conservatives
warned us would make things even worse
but the sky didn't fall unemployment did
and growth shot up to over four percent
and a twenty six billion dollar deficit
became an 11 billion dollar surplus
for a rainy day whatever that is
and that is mostly because we horror of
Horrors raise taxes on the rich FoxNews
said we were insane that the rich would
flee the state I mean what does Laguna
Beach have for wealthy people that they
can't find in Nebraska
folks if states are laboratories of
democracy why are we wasting time
replicating failed experiments I thought
the idea behind science is that you try
something and if it doesn't work you try
something else you run these experiments
so you can see which ones work and the
ones that do are replicated to other
states and the ones that don't are sent
to Florida
you